john baker usually drives
2 000 miles a week but since wednesday
he's been sleeping here
in his cab in a hollyhead car park
watching lorries pile up around him we
were clearing up from
going into the dock itself and onto the
dual carriageway there
and they were it was a stand still
john's been waiting for days for goods
to arrive from ireland
if brexit means more delays like this
it's a worrying glimpse of how his work
will change
you go into docs they check you
those are checks you the police check
you so we don't need no more
checks you're there 20 minutes half an
hour
and then that puts you behind then then
the company is ringing you saying
why are you delayed and then you explain
to him
what can you do the port here is busier
than it's ever been
20 percent more freight is moving ahead
of the brexit deadline
yesterday that combined with bad weather
and covert closures
meant this an a road that became a car
park
we've come to the top of this very windy
hill to get a true sense of the scale
of the operation here at holly head
force and it's absolutely enormous and
you'd expect that this is the uk's
second
busiest port and you also get a sense
that if there's even a small
delay here it could have a significant
impact
on what's happening around the town and
after two years of
planning there's now just weeks to avoid
more of this the last thing we want to
see
is you know empty shelves on certain
products because of the delays it ports
we keep finding ways you know i have
spoken to businesses where if they see
there's a problem in one port
they're moving their supply chains to
another port and that's as opposed to
the beauty of the logistics industry we
can react
quickly
yesterday's cues were a test of how
authorities might cope
but people that live here say they feel
this is an accident
waiting to happen to get into hollyhead
itself is absolutely blocked
we missed three or four green lights
just stuck there because
all the lorries had come through red
lights and just blocked everywhere and
we couldn't move
and remember this is just a taste of
things to come
the real trial is ahead catering over
totsi sky news
in hollyhead
you